in the age of YouTube and fanatic
fandoms something either has to be a
masterpiece or an atrocity to Garner
more views and attention but Ahsoka is
really neither of those things and at
least to me Falls right into the middle
and is just decent I'm not going to sit
here and complain about how females have
taken over Star Wars or whatever that
complaint is and just care about the
pure quality of the show there are
definite strengths Ahsoka has and there
are also some big issues that hold it
back first going into what I think is
the show's major flaw that really hints
me from enjoying it is the fact that
there are no Stakes or tension that's
primarily in reference to an action
perspective but before going into that
the show's inherent premise is already
spoiled from the get-go so you always
know exactly where the story is going
thus destroying any suspense as to what
happens because throughout the show
treats the question and threat as if
Thon is returning as this big point of
mystery and conflict however through
marketing and then publicly casting
thron we know right away that he will
return it becomes this inevitability
instead of a question as to if it will
happen nothing the characters do have
Stakes because we already know the
outcome beforehand this isn't
necessarily A Fault to the writing and
instead the inherent nature of the show
and how it was packaged although I think
the story does a good job at combating
this by having a protagonist overcome
obstacles in more creative ways after a
simple solution is snuffed out like in
the beginning when the information from
the puzzle was stolen and negotiating
with a space well for safe passage to a
new Galaxy so even though we know the
outcome come the process of getting
there is so relatively interesting and
not very obvious it holds just enough of
a hook within the audience to keep your
attention throughout the series now
going back to the tension and Stakes for
action scenes this is an aspect about
the show that really drove me crazy and
every single lightsaber fight scene
besides the final fight with Morgan
where finally someone actually dies the
heroes and villains walk away unscathed
and it's as if we're just watching
skirmishes with no consequences it
becomes extremely contrived for
characters to survive these combat
encounters but the creators want to
artificially inject more action into the
series and through each action scene
they expose the plot armor these
characters are wearing more and more
like the most egregious example is
Sabine we have the infamous opening
where she gets skewered by a lightsaber
and is fine but the writers hilariously
do this again essentially by having Shin
simply leave before killing Sabine in
episode 4 she disarms her and knocks her
onto the ground but Sabine shoots her
once Shin drops her lightsaber and and
then pieces out with a smoke bomb like
she could easily just kill her here
since she lost track of her and can
force grab her lightsaber but hey we
need sub be for later then when she
shows up to stop Balin and grabs the
artifact Balin can simply Force pull it
out of her hand and kill her but he
instead opts to make a deal to
artificially keep her alive every
episode is full of these glaring
examples of plot armor and contrivances
to the point that invalidates all danger
you know that every single lightsaber
fight ends with no casualties and it's
insane that they have about three of
them and nothing major happens without
any tension or Stakes it makes the
action extremely dull and generally what
Saves Action if that is the case is
great choreography however I wouldn't
say a single lightsaber fight in the
show was remarkable and all came off as
being Bland and the big issue is that we
have so many examples of great
lightsaber fights to the point that if
you ever draw a comparison from those to
Ahsoka they utterly blow Ahsoka out of
the water they aren't Dynamic the
lightsaber choreography is generally
pretty generic with rare spicy moves the
choreography is at times slow and clunky
as if they didn't have enough rehearsal
time and even the locations in which the
fight scenes take place does nothing for
the action also another aspect that I
think hurts these lightsaber fights is
the constant usage of parallel editing
now parallel editing is when you cut
back and forth between two separate
scenes happening at the same time within
the story generally this is fine but the
way they utilize parallel editing in
Ahsoka is at times really annoying
mainly because they spend all this time
building up to a lightsaber Showdown and
then the second they start fighting they
cut away to another Scene It robs you of
that excitement you slowly build up
leading to this major moment just for it
to instantly dissipate at times it feels
like a copout because their budget may
not be big enough to show us an
uninterrupted lightsaber duel and
instead just small chunks here and there
I want to see the whole story of the
fight in the E and flow of who is
winning instead of jarringly being
thrown in and out of it then every other
type of action scene is also plagued
with the same issues of constant usages
of contrivances and plot armor from
spaceship combat being completely
nonsensical in which enemy Fighters can
endlessly shoot a Sila ship and
constantly Miss and do nothing or if
they do damage it like in the finale
huyang is able to repair it in like 30
minutes somehow and there's just no
consequences or the normal fights with
Stormtroopers in which they are never
shooting the protagnist when they're in
Clear Sight the biggest example is when
they are all surrounded at the end of
episode 7 and and when Ahsoka shows up
they literally all just start running
away instead of overwhelming her with
blasters or literally just becoming
Immortal and rushing an open field with
the Star Destroyer riging hell down on
them and none of them sustaining any
casualties like I know Obi-Wan in the
book of Boba Fett were bad but holy
these examples are on the same level and
if not even worse at times I know Dave
filon is a more competent writer than
John fabra which I'll get into in a
second but he still suffers from
regularly using contrivances to make his
story work the infuriating thing about
Ahsoka is that if these major issues
were fixed the show would be
significantly better but it's just
plagued by that cheap Disney Plus show
feel where all the action feels rushed
botched and plagued with apparent
writing
issues wait wait
wait we
could talk moving on to another aspect
let's go into the characters ironically
and this is rarely the case I loved all
the antagonist and none of the
protagonist I didn't hate hate them and
mostly think they are pretty generic
with not a lot interesting happening
under the hood Ahsoka was devoid of
personality and it was just this simple
zen-like figure so much to the point
that she kind of gave me pretentious
Vibes as to this is how Jedi should act
when in reality all the most interesting
Jedi characters had very colorful
personalities and had certain quirks
that made them so lovable like Obi-Wan's
civil nature and Anakin's Reckless
albeit effective nature Ahsoka doesn't
really have anything going for her and
she mostly comes across as a dull figure
she doesn't have a character Arc in her
own show and even the quote unquote best
part of the series about her flashback
doesn't really add much to her character
I like the sequence and enjoyed it but
if you really take a look at it within
the context of the entire season you
could effectively remove it and nothing
changes unfortunately it's cool to see
her confront Anakin again and their
discussion was infinitely more engaging
than anything with Sabine so much to the
point that I'd rather we just have
gotten a liveaction clone wars show but
Ahsoka really doesn't learn any
Revelations along with this introducing
more mechanics within the universe that
are confusing like if a Jedi is on the
brink of death do they always go to this
mind Palace area where they fight for
their life that conveniently slows down
their heart rate for an hour as they
await to be saved I like this concept in
theory but its implementation is
undeniably messy and kind of confusing
not to mention that Hera randomly brings
her four sensitive son to a dangerous
combat Mission just so that he can hear
aokin in Anakin's lsrael which
essentially brings up the point that for
every good aspect in the show it's
immediately counterbalanced by something
bad and my main assumption is that Star
Wars fans are more blind to these faults
or are much more accepting and forgiving
of them I've seen Star Wars fans say
this scene gave them full body chills
and I just don't understand that level
of attachment to this franchise anymore
given Disney's handling of the IP like
we were all like that for the force
awakens but in this day and age after so
much heinous they've done to the
franchise I don't have that level of
blind type for Star Wars and I'm more
critical now then for Sabine I see a lot
of hate for her character and that she
shouldn't be for sensitive but I don't
care if she has two ex chrum zomes
especially since the last shedi
establishes the notion that anyone can
be for sensitive and has to be unlocked
with intense training and some people
are obviously more powerful than others
I don't know if people are just deleting
this out of their personal head Cannon
and at this point in the Star Wars
Universe there have been so many cooks
in the kitchen that there is so much
conflicting points within the lore so
since I'm defending her here you may
assume I like the character and that
would be wrong because I don't I found
her to be largely annoying given her
dominant selfish and rebellious nature
which is fine from a character
standpoint but the writers utterly screw
her over in episode 4 by her choosing to
condemn the entire galaxy she chooses to
bring back Thon which will most likely
lead to another War just so that she can
see her friend again this event
immediately disconnects you from the
character and I personally grew so much
hatred for her because of this day
thinks that this gives the character
more depth because she's missing that
connection to family within her life but
at the entire expense of the Galaxy
really it just doesn't seem justifiable
at all and I'm really surprised she
isn't condemned for doing this later on
like she literally faces no consequences
or at least so far there's also some
other characters that I won't touch on
for the sake of time like Hara who I
thought was fine and huy yang out of all
of them though actually enjoyed Huang
the most which kind of feels sad for the
state of the main characters for the
intact
the clear standout is obviously thrawn
like holy I knew he was a favorite
but when he shows up the show goes from
mediocre to Great his screen presence is
immediately felt and surges with so much
menacing energy that you genuinely feel
fear just by him staring at you which is
also a testament to the brilliant design
of the character the cold calculating
meticulous nature of the character is so
fresh in comparison to other Empire
villains who generally feel more
cartoonish and mustache twirly he's
never underestimating his threat and is
actually strategizing in real time
against his opponents Star Wars
protagonists were always able to exploit
the fact that they were under estimated
by their adversaries but here it seems
like thron is actually trying his best
to win although the story is still
pretty contrived in that he could simply
order a TIE fighter strike on the hermit
crab Convoy and decimate them
but hey what do I know about military
strategy I just have a useless
bachelor's degree in film studies at the
very least though he actually wins and
it makes se's to or I guess a movie
maybe actually exciting because there's
a lot of potential for what can be done
with the character and his story I'd
assume they'd overcome and kill him in
the end but how much damage he does and
who he kills before then is the main
question then there are also some other
Sith characters that are generally
pretty intriguing especially Balon the
character has a lot of class and he's
actually honorable and is pretty witty
he has a lot of depth and history and
like thraw he has a great scream
presence it's just too bad that the main
story for his character is primarily
being reserved for the next season and
it's also unfortunate that Ray Stevenson
passed away hopefully they recast him
and don't leave him on that literal
Cliffhanger and Perpetual limbo then
finally we have Shin who I also think
has an infectious screen presence she's
so expressive with her eyes and so much
hate pours through them to the point
that she's cutting into your soul she
does a lot with so little which I think
is a testament to how great of an actor
she is along with her character having
such an off-kilter design that makes her
General figure kind of disturbing and
terrifying it's it's just a bit
unfortunate that she didn't have a lot
to do within the story and she was kind
of screwed over by the many contrivances
of the writing but hopefully she has a
bigger role in season 2 with more of an
arc going into some more positives for
the show I think the overall
productivity and Pace was much better
than John favos in the Mandalorian
because if this was written by him the
season would have ended with the reveal
of thron in episode 6 and in that time
he would have injected a bunch of
side quests to Pat out the
length of the Season instead day Fon
delivers a real and coherent Pace to the
point that it's finally a positive
aspect now like this should be something
that's a given I've seen some people
still complain that the show is too slow
but I think a lot of the down moments
are still filled with productive usage
of character developments albeit quite a
bit of it isn't engaging enough to
really be that entertaining and I
understand the critique that nothing
happens in the show which is flat out
wrong but people probably think that
because the show is essentially pitched
as thraw returning and that doesn't
happen till the end of the season which
again is a problem with how they sold
the show Dave filon at times also
delivers some genuinely Great Moments
within the story like zombie
Stormtroopers I think that was easily
the best setpiece and was actually a
moment where I felt an ounce of danger
for Our Heroes because the enemy was
threatening for once although they're
literally wielding lightsabers and can
dismember them but whatever that's more
of a nitpick instead of a major issue
also another aspect about his writing
and his directing that I think he Nails
is the tone it really reminds me of old
school Star Wars and when it was even
inspired by which was a kurak Kurosawa
George Lucas was heavily influenced by
his Samurai thums and essentially took
the samurai gave them laser swords and
the force and shipped them off to a
galaxy far far away and called them Jedi
day filon harnesses this original
inspiration and applies it to great
effect in Ahsoka like the buildup to
every fight being slow and methodical as
the music slowly builds your excitement
an example I still love is the first
fight scene where ahoka is ambushed by
some droids who are also hunting for the
map their introduction is intimida and
mysterious and just hammers home that
Samurai tone so well just don't think
about how they don't instantly activate
their self-destruct and conveniently
wait for Ahsoka to clear the area again
for every good aspect there has to be
something that weighs it down then since
I briefly brought it up I think that
music was great throughout the series
it's very prominent in Ahsoka and really
emphasizes and elevates each scene along
with it expertly punctuating select
important moments I really love the end
credit theme and pretty much every show
besides maybe Obi-Wan has had
outstanding music the Mandalorian though
is still top tier and that's just
because Ludwick Goron is basically the
next Han Zimmer so yeah from an overall
Outlook I think Ahsoka is kind of
mediocre and just by having this opinion
I assume this video won't do well since
I'm not playing to any of the two
extreme sides of Love or hate there's a
lot more Nuance surrounding Ahsoka in
terms of strengths and flaws and to me
the best way to fix some of those issues
as if day filon wasn't the sole writer
for the show through Andor we've gotten
a taste of what great Star Wars writing
could look like instead of the shallow
Adventure we got thank you for watching
and let me know in the comments what you
thought about
Ahsoka